conan please meet marin oh hey marin how
are you
great to meet you how do you spell your
first name marin uh
the way that it's spelled on the screen
m-e-r-i-n
uh oh wow you just okay boomered me that
was so
that was so mean my mom is an anti-aging
activist conan so she's gonna give me a
lot of [ __ ] for that lady first of all
i gotta fix it so that you're up all the
time because you're you're
you keep disappearing when you're not
speaking so i didn't when
you you weren't on screen at that second
and i couldn't see how you had spelled
your name
and you tore into me with a violence and
a vehemence
that was um i don't know it was brutal
that was brutal you're already making me
feel really welcome conan thank you
uh well i listen i i i feel like we got
off on the wrong start
okay uh i simply asked you how you spell
your name
you okay boomered me uh now i'm just a
smoldering wreck
no i thought we were gonna talk about me
but as i have uh
observed pretty frequently on the
podcast with matt and sonap hi by the
way
uh you didn't introduce them or present
them in any way
but also you've already turned it
completely around to yourself so i'm
very impressed by just the speed
i like marin marin
darren marin marin
[Music]
first of all i resent that uh the fact
that you think i
turn everything to me that's just not
true i'm a curious mind
a gracious host i always make it about
the guest
well for one conan you clearly have your
zoom on speaker view
which means that you're also mostly
staring at yourself
oh my god oh wow
this is amazing i have found
popcorn whenever i become agitated or
upset if i see my face i calm down
it's why sometimes you put a mirror in a
crib a child just relaxes when it sees
itself
so yes i do have it uh on speaker view
um but marin i want you to do most the
talking because it sounds like
you are a very analytical mind you're
very good at reading
people you've outed me already as not
being good
at tech and uh you've revealed to a
shocked public that i'm a narcissist
so congratulations um so tell us
tell me about yourself what do you do
where are you from yeah so
i'm from the midwest generally
i was born in canada oh so you roam
around a lot
you're like a serial killer you move
quickly from town to town
yes shockingly similar yes uh i
lived in minnesota for a long time
that's where like my family is from
but i actually live in mexico city
that's where i am right now
and oh you're in mexico home yeah and uh
i work for the fulbright commission here
i came as a fulbrighter and then i
stayed on working for the commission so
i've been in mexico now almost
three years and i love it this is a
fulbright scholarship
or did you wow congratulations you're
clearly a very accomplished person
thank you seriously i mean that i love
mexico city or as i
call it mexico uh but
sorry i'll i'll i'll uh i'll translate
that later for everyone
um have you been to my favorite spot to
visit
in mexico city which is where trotsky
was murdered have you been to trotsky's
home of course
yes many times that's i always take
people there when they visit you know
what i've been there
and uh there were two attempts on
trotsky's life and the first one was
with machine guns and there's still
holes in the wall
the second one famously worked where
they hired an intern
to work for trotsky and he worked for
them for a while and then when no one
was looking
because he was a plant from the soviet
union he wandered in and put an
ice pick in trotsky's head which i think
he still holds
the uh award for worst intern because
i mean you just you think about it like
people say like oh that intern was
terrible never got my coffee order right
yeah i have another one for you walked
in and put an ice pick in the boss's
brain well you better watch out because
sona i think is
about at her limit as it is yes i can
send you an
amazon link to a really great ice pick
store please
yeah a lot of good options a lot of
different sizes
you know it's not going to leave a trace
here's the problem sona's going to get
the ice she's going to order the ice
pick she's going to get the ice pick
she's going to be all ready to go
she's going to be headed in to kill me
with the ice pick
and on the way into the office she's
going to forget okay
later on you'll be driving home and
there'll be an ice pick in your purse
and you're like oh
[ __ ] you're having a good time second
tries the challenge thank you marin
i know marin believes in me one day you
will have a nice pick sticking out of
your head
you're welcome to come and visit him
here in mexico here's another fun fact
about trotsky he gets the ice pick in
the head
it literally is sticking out of his head
just like sona described he gets up
and fights the guy with an ice pick
sticking out of his head it was like a
warner brothers cartoon it's insane
uh anyway look it up online death of
trotsky
fascinating